he is the commissioner of the pac-12
he's larry scott back on the program
commissioner good morning thanks for
joining us
what has changed since the last time we
spoke
well we announced yesterday a
groundbreaking
partnership with quiddell
california-based
testing company i was the first to be
approved for
what people refer to as these
point-of-care
rapid result tests where you basically
get a result in
15 minutes and we think this is a game
changer for
us because our medical advisors said
this is the only way they can be
confident that if we're asking student
athletes
to go practice in a high context sport
like football or basketball for example
the only way we can be confident we're
not incurred encouraging the spread
of the virus and that's kind of a
standard of care our medical advisors
and our presidents have felt that we
should apply
you know we're asking student athletes
to participate in activity it's not
recommended
by the cdc it's not a socially distanced
activity
so it's been a sense we've had and we've
been you know on one end of the spectrum
here
that there's a moral and ethical
responsibility for students to not put
them in
more harm's way than they'd be in
otherwise and by by being able to test
a student athlete every day before they
go into practice or
game we can have a high degree of
confidence
that no one in practice or a game has
the coronavirus and could spread it so
this is an important step in the path to
us reconsidering resumption of play
how soon is this test going to be
available so we um
you know signed and announced the
agreement yesterday we're going to have
all the materials sent to our schools uh
by the end of this month
and so by the beginning of october we're
going to be able to start
start the testing and we're also doing a
research project for the company
on uh you know how young mostly
asymptomatic
healthy student athletes what's the
impact of being able to test daily
because
you know our universities do a lot of
research you know we're working on
some of these vexing challenges with
covet and in athletics we're gonna have
a big test case
and uh you know there's a thesis that
this kind of daily testing with rapid
results
could also be the answer to return to
school for k-12 kids
return to work and you know society and
the economy getting back to normal so
there's another component of that too um
so you know but to answer your question
october we'll be in kind of full testing
mode
if the test goes well is the pac-12 in
business playing football this fall
um i believe we will be whether it's in
the fall or january first remains to be
seen
you know this is isn't unfortunately our
only challenge we've got six schools
currently then
the four california schools ucla usc
stanford and cal and two of our oregon
schools oregon and oregon state
that don't currently have government
approvals to have contact practice i
know
the approvals have been given for pro
sports but not for college
sports so we'll need some help from the
counties public health officials to
bless this and say it's okay
now i think what we announced yesterday
is gonna be an important piece of that i
think the public health officials are
keenly interested in what our plans and
protocols are
so i'm hopeful that we will get what we
need but as it is now you're not going
to play fall football
no as it is now uh we had made a
decision
um several weeks ago and this doesn't
change that
it could it does it doesn't yet uh again
we don't have government approvals yet
if we get the government approvals and
uh we can implement this testing
uh certainly we could uh you know
basketball
um it looks like the ncaa is going to uh
change the start date of basketball
season from november 10th to probably
november 25th or later so that's
probably the first decision
we got to take can we revisit the
decision not play basketball before
january 1st
and maybe start the season at the same
date or close to
when the rest of the country is and then
on a parallel
path we've got a way up does it make
sense to start the football season in
late november
early december or does it make sense to
you know get through finals
for the student athletes get through the
christmas holidays and start in january
one of our considerations gonna be um
you know trying to move in tandem with
the big ten
if we can it's a little unclear where
they are what they're gonna do despite
me talking to their commissioner
every day but um you know if the two of
our conferences can move together we've
got
pretty exciting vision of playing you
know big ten pac-12 seasons
finishing with a pac-12 championship big
ten championship
and then playing a rose bowl and other
bowl games at the end of the season
even if it's an early spring game so
ohio state
or michigan or whoever in the big ten
wisconsin leading this charge of maybe
coming back this fall
but you're talking about trying to be in
conjunction with the big ten
in the spring or winter spring not fall
correct yeah
well we've laid out that you know vision
that it would be there would be benefits
in us moving in tandem
obviously we don't control that as it's
been clear each one of the conferences
makes their own decisions
so look we've got to stay nimble uh and
flexible and there's a dynamic situation
i think it'll it'll evolve over the next
couple weeks i think there'll be more
clarity
on the big ten side i know they're
hopeful to get access
to the kind of daily rapid result
testing that we have which again
yeah real breakthrough in terms of
medical
community at least in the big ten and
pac-12 being comfortable
with a resumption of play um and if we
can move together that would be best if
we can't we can't we could we can only
control what we control
but also if you're looking at uh the
president's had a vote in the big ten
and i don't know what role the
commissioner had you know kevin warren
had
uh the same with the pac-12 are you
going to have your presidents
voting on this or do you decide on if
there's going to be
false sports basketball if there's going
to be winter sports uh spring sports
who decides it works the same way in in
all of our leagues
the presidents ultimately decide they're
the board okay
so yeah we're we're the chief executives
we're expected to do the groundwork to
make a recommendation at the end of the
day they decide how much pressure is on
you
it's a tremendous amount of pressure i
mean there's been so much anxiety
and uncertainty um you know we're
responsible for
a lot of people whether it's in our
conference office
at the universities and then 7 000
student athletes and every one of those
groups
has been dealing in a world of uh
anxiety and uncertainty
you know for our student athletes
they're the ones i'm concerned most
about i mean
being a student athlete being able to
participate in your sport is an
important part of like who you are
and your identity and and going to
school and so it's been heart-wrenching
to see these opportunities be postponed
for these student athletes who are eager
to play but at the same time
they expect us as the adults in the room
and their parents there and i've spoken
to their parents too
on zoom calls and others you know expect
us to have their health and well-being
in mind
not just for the season but you know for
the rest of their life too
yeah i thought that uh the pac-12 was
dead uh you guys
are breathing you know some life back
into this sports program you guys were
quiet and i didn't know if that was a
good thing
uh the big ten is quiet right now and i
don't know if that's a good thing but
it feels like that when you guys are
quiet that things are happening behind
the scenes there
and um i think that was the case here
yeah
well we we've certainly been uh working
hard
at this um trying to solve for these
things you know we've been more measured
than other leagues you know we've let
the science and data
guide us uh there's a lot of emotion
around this too but we've tried to block
that out
and you know on the on on the west coast
um you know i think our universities
have athletics i think in a pretty
healthy
perspective um you know you see the part
of the broader
you know community of our universities
and uh we're gonna follow the
the health and medical uh guidelines and
not not make exceptions so
that's why we had to wait until the kind
of thing we announced yesterday which
changes the game for us
uh because we can look any constituency
in the eye and say
we are not putting your son and daughter
at risk
but how do you explain this though
commissioner that the sec
and the big 12 and the acc are playing
through this
same information i'm going to guess it's
same information
and uh look i you know there's a lot of
pressure on everyone
and you know there's different
priorities different parts of the
country so
uh you know i respect whatever decisions
they're making they're under different
pressures
you know um uh but yeah i think college
football is a microcosm of what's going
on in our country
you know the same data in science is out
there and governors and other officials
are making different decisions about
mask wearing
whether bars should be open or not
whether k-12
should be open or not so um you know not
not a great moment in our country
in that regard that the same science and
data is being applied differently and
college football is not an exception
yeah that's what i i've
said to as many people as possible why
can't we get
the pac-12 commissioners and have their
medical teams
get together on a zoom call just to be
able to exchange ideas larry
i this doesn't make sense and it's
i know that there's priorities that are
different in the south than they are in
the west and then the midwest i get all
of that
but man we can't play political games
with this
we want to play games not political
games i agree what i will tell you is
there is an amazing collaboration
between the
conferences including the medical
advisers they speak every week
so the information's being shared you
know it's at the decision-making level
you know you asked before who makes the
decision it's the presidents and
chancellors of universities
and if you're part of a public
university you've got a higher authority
you work for too right your state yeah
so uh just that has to be kept in mind
you know the
the commissioners our medical advisors
are very very collaborative
we've tried to move together but when
the decisions get made
you know they're made by the leaders of
our universities
but if all goes well commissioner when
is the pac-12 playing football
well right now um i've got high degree
confidence we're playing
in january okay it's possible because
this announcement we
we could play sooner so i think the
significance of yesterday's announcement
having access to this testing
is you know i can look in the eye
virtually and tell you i've got a high
degree of confidence we're playing
just on a post bone base we're gonna
have a full exciting season
uh for our student athletes well i
shouldn't say full as in
playing 12 games i think it will be
abbreviated like it is in other
conferences
um what's now also possible is we could
start earlier than january but that's
going to depend on some things outside
our control like public health
authorities and
and making the decision does it make
sense to start at the end of the year
just wait to the beginning of the year
how are you doing fully recovered from
uh coronavirus
thanks for asking yep that was just
another layer of anxiety i went through
it my whole family got it
um uh it spread very quickly through our
household but
thankfully fully recovered several weeks
ago and got my stamina back and back to
working out but
yeah there's a lot of unknowns about
this certainly with all the members of
my family it affected everyone a little
differently
good to visit with you have a good
weekend and uh good luck with this
thanks dan appreciate you having me
that's uh larry scott back 12
commissioner